my name is Chad and i'm scott kennedy
and the name of your project guys I feel
it's not lying right here and the
website ww-why right here calm and what
inspired leg right now there's a writer
and a plan I got the script remember
that i had the opportunity to rework it
let them throw my special in herbs
spices on it
and I want to shoot came together at all
these amazingly talented people helped
me out and made a film demanded of your
customers listen said Garrett Morris
actually he was able to producer was one
of the original Saturday Night Live cast
no worse and he said he's like a hero my
cuz he went to Juilliard School music
arrangements for I looked out for
meeting with Chad because
and how did you raise money Wow actually
I a mixture of balls tenacity and
perseverance I guess I just made a lot
of phone calls thought got a lot of my
friends doors and I called a lot of
different companies got a few sponsors
worked out